bei diesem turnier weiß man bei der
deutschen mannschaft noch ein bisschen
weniger wo sie vor dem ersten spiel
steht ja also das letzte spiel gegen
saudi arabien hat die eine oder andere
frage aufgeworfen
aber eben auch die diskussion die es und
özil und gündogan gibt weitergibt mit
der ganzen erdogan affäre
wie sehr das die mannschaft beeinflusst
hat das sind das wissen wir noch nicht
so genau und wir werden aber jetzt sehen
ob sich das sportlich in irgendeiner
weise auswirkt ob er sich auf die
einzelnen spieler auswirkt ob er sich
auf die atmosphäre im stadion ausrichten
was das dann mit der mannschaft macht
man weiß ja auch nicht wie die
mannschaft mit dieser frage umgegangen
ist meine seele und gründer haben auch
nicht allzu viel dafür getan um die
irritationen auszuräumen gegen mexiko
werden wir schon sehen wie sich das
tatsächlich auf dem platz dann
ausgewirkt hat oder eben auch nicht
aber es gibt eben auch die eine oder
andere position die sagen nicht 100
prozent weltmeister nicht besetzt das
außenverteidiger frage links da wird man
sehen gegen starke gegner ist es so
verlässlich anderer punkt ist bisschen
fehlende körperliche dynamik im
defensiven mittelfeld also um die
körperliche präsenz dort also das muss
man noch mal sehen ob man das sagen
rein spielerisch auffangen kann und ob
das reicht und die dritte vielleicht
auch entscheidende frage die
durchschlagskraft wir haben bisher in
der nationalmannschaft eben noch nicht
den topstürmer der internationalen
weltklassestürmer darstellt timo werner
kann es werden hat große anlagen und
trägt auch viele hoffnungen in sich man
muss mal schauen was mit reus ist die
aus dem mittelfeld vielleicht
erfolgreich nach vorne stossen kann was
mit thomas müller ist aber so 100% sich
darauf zu verlassen wie man sich auf den
ronaldo verlassen kann und vielleicht
auf den einen oder anderen stürmer aus
frankreich oder aus spanien dass das ist
bei der nationalmannschaft in dem fall
aus meiner sicht noch nicht so gegeben
ich fürchte dass das über sieben spiele
hinweg irgendwann nicht mehr reichen
wird
aber ich denke dass man gegen mexiko
schweden und südkorea das sich die
mannschaft dort qualifizieren wird für
das achtelfinale
ich denke auch dass sie sich als
gruppensieger qualifizieren wird aber
das erste spiel denke ich dass wir das
schwierigste sein auch gegen den
stärksten gegnern also das wird schon
ein schlüsselspiel für die vorrunde
werden
[Musik]